[Musik]
[Applaus]
10 hat die deutsche
frauenfußball-nationalmannschaft das
auftaktspiel der weltmeisterschaft in
frankreich für sich entschieden
hier im rohr sonntag in rennen hinter
mir hat sie eine durchwachsene leistung
gezeigt die sorgen bereitet weil sich
unsicherheiten in der abwehr
eingeschlichen haben die ein anderer
gegner wahrscheinlich effektiver genutzt
hätte als die chinesinnen für die
deutsche mannschaft darf sich bedanken
bei torhüterin almuth schult die einmal
kopf und kragen riskiert um den
rückstand für verhindern und vor allem
dann auch bei julia quinn die in der
zweiten halbzeit das erlösende tor
schoss hoffnung für das deutsche spiel
weckt allerdings dass in der pause
bei lena oberdorf ins spiel gebracht
wurde eine erst 17 jahre und fünf monate
alte spielerin von der sg essen die dem
spiel deutlich stabilität verliehen
sie ist auch eine wirkliche alternative
für die startelf im nächsten spiel am
kommenden mittwoch gegen spanien
wenn die deutsche elf sich steigern muss
in der abwehrreihe die gegen china doch
viele fragen offen ließ
gerade die unsicherheit von saragossa im
passspiel waren doch heute
furchterregend und geben anlass zur
sorge für sich verbuchen kann
bundestrainer martina voss tecklenburg
das den mut gehabt hat mit ihrem
trainerteam in der pause sich für die
umstellung und die einwechslung von lena
oberdorf zu entscheiden die bundeswehr
sagte nachher auch im turnierverlauf ist
es wichtig widerstände zu überwinden
das kann dieser welt positiv für sich
verbuchen und damit weiter arbeiten an
den schwächen die wir heute auch
offenbart
[Musik]